Let's go next to let's go to Mohammed from
Qatar.
I don't believe we've ever had a call from
Qatar before.
Mohammed, what's on your mind?
Mohamed, you have to unmuted if you want me
to be able to hear you.
Mohammed from Qatar, I would love for you
to be the first Qatari caller, but that's
probably not going to happen the way things
are looking.
All right, no Mohammed from Qatar, that's
too bad.
That's too bad.
I was really looking forward to that.
Let's go to or from Milwaukee, Wisconsin.
David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Oh, great.
Thank you again for taking my call.
I just wanted to talk a little bit about,
I guess, the student loans and the crisis
that's going on with that.
Clearly, the Biden administration and congressional
Democrats are aiming at canceling some form
of back, whether that be five thousand to
fifty thousand.
Yep.
It seems that there are some subsector of
of America that is a little bit hesitant to
it for various reasons, whether that be paying
them down already or not having it in the
first place, although it does seem that the
majority of Americans do support that.
And I guess my question would be, how do we
address that?
Would there possibly be in the long term versus
just obviously clearly.
Canceling some portion of that debt is going
to alleviate some of the issue in the short
term, but the long term, it seems to me that
predatory loans are maybe more of the issue
rather than the actual.
Yep.
So here's here's my view.
Because of if we were rebuilding the system
from scratch, we would just build it in a
different way.
That would prevent the cycle of it's so easy
to get student loans, which makes it easy
for colleges to raise prices because then
you just get the loans and then you owe more
money.
But wages don't go up and it becomes unsustainable,
which is what we have.
That's the crisis that we have.
We would build the system differently.
But being that we are where we are, there
should be some degree of student loan forgiveness.
And I've seen a lot of different proposals
about what that should be and how it should
be targeted.
As I've said before, it doesn't strike me
that the right way to do it is to forgive
every dollar of student debt for everybody.
That doesn't make sense to me, but I think
that some fixed amount plus more with certain
requirements attached to it is a good way
to go.
But you're completely right that that doesn't
really solve the problem, because if you just
have a policy of we forgive everyone's loans
forever, then schools just keep making school
more expensive and, you know, the cycle essentially
continues.
So I think you kind of get back into the same
cycle where, you know, we're going to wipe
the slate clean, but then we haven't really
address the root issue of the problem.
Exactly what I'm thinking in my head is it
doesn't make sense to maybe go with or establish
some sort of a federal loan program where
there is a little to no interest rate lower
or providing federal dollars as a loan.
So that exists already that that exists already
for grad school.
I had I had the federal loans where interest
accrual is suspended for periods of time.
And so so that that exists, it could be expanded.
I think ultimately something needs to be done
to bring the cost of college in line with
with wages.
Because if you look at how the cost of college
has changed relative to wages in many fields,
it's completely out of whack.
If you look at cost of college relative to
inflation, relative to cost of living, it's
completely out of whack.
So that's what needs to be gotten under control.
I'm not saying the government just needs to
decide what prices are that does that.
You know, I don't think that that's the solution.
Government sets prices on private and public
schooling, but something needs to get done,
be done to reign to get that under control.
And the student loan piece is a problem that
subsidizes colleges continuing to charge more
and more.
And a one time debt forgiveness is not going
to deal with that issue.
All right.
Well, thanks again for taking my call.
I really appreciate it.
My pleasure.
Very important issue or I appreciate the call.